[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces vieux tout ça 23 septembre 1990 dans
la salle il y en a qui l'ont connu dans
la salle il y en a qui l'ont pas vu pour
moi c'était une époque assez étrange je
rentrais en sem est en cm1 je sais pas
si vous vous souvenez mais en début
d'année on vous demande toujours de
faire quelque chose qu'est ce que tu vas
faire quand tu seras grand
alors on écrit sur un petit papier et on
le donne à la prof moi dans ma classe y
avait des gens qui avaient déjà beaucoup
d'ambitions naquit voulais être
vétérinaire médecin pompier
moi j'avais décidé quand même d'avoir un
métier beaucoup plus humble dans ma vie
je voulais top model
ça arrive en walter ça dépend je voulais
choisir entre les deux gt gt encore dans
le doute
sauf que la réponse que j'ai eu de la
part de ma prof m'a profondément choqué
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
emmanuel j'ai demandé un métier c'est
pas un hobby un tu crois vraiment tu vas
réussir ta vie comme ça s'en est suivie
les railleries de ma classe hyper bien
je veux dire on met en confiance
l'enfant que j'étais dans le cadre de
mon projet pour la suite super il ya ce
moment il ya quelque chose qui est
apparue en moi une sorte de désir
une boule qui grandissait qui en tête
qui est en train de prendre place qui
devenait de l'énergie et je me disais
pas capable je suis pas capable je suis
pas capable
[Musique]
et à partir de là mon but c'était quoi
de lui prouver que j'étais capable de
devenir quelque chose
mais cette idée là je n'ai pas eu juste
pour être top model j'ai eu toute ma vie
et ça va donner un truc un peu spécial
c'est à dire qu'en gros toute ma vie a
été des défis j'ai fais du sport je suis
devenu champion de france de water-polo
ouais j'ai réussi ensuite à gagné un
golden globe awards alors que je suis
nul en orthographe
ensuite je suis devenu entrepreneur j'ai
créé une plateforme pour aider les gens
à communiquer j'ai écrit un bouquin pour
faire plaisir à un moment et ensuite
j'ai fait un one man show
et là vous allez me dire mais top model
menu pas je suis devenu mister camping
je me suis arrêté là parce que je me
suis dit que ce n'est pas la peine en
fait je me suis rendu compte que quelque
chose d'important à ce moment là je
cherchais le nom que je pouvais donner à
ce sentiment que j'avais eue alors
certains m'ont dit que c'était du
dépassement de soi j'ai dit oui sauf que
le dépassement de soi ça nous amène à
faire quelque chose quand on n'a pas
confiance
sauf que là au fil des expériences
j'arrive à avoir confiance en moi donc
j'ai transformé j'ai un pli sa de
l'ambition le désir ardent que vous avez
de parvenir à quelque chose c'est plus
fort que vous vous avez envie d'y
arriver
vous n'avez que ça dans la tête et c'est
bon c'est bon en plus aujourd'hui vous
le savez on en parle beaucoup il y à
plat davantage d'ambition on a confiance
en nous on fait des focus sur soi même
on réussit à mieux comprendre l'échec on
est persévérant enfin bref tout ce qu on
devrait apprendre à l'école on l'apprend
par le biais de l'ambition c'est superbe
c'est magnifique c'est magnifique c'est
magnifique
ouais c'est magnifique bah pas tant que
ça en fait dans la vie à une règle
simple s'il ya quelque chose de bien il
y a quelque chose de mal et
malheureusement l'ambition ne déroge pas
à la règle
l'ambition est une toute petite un tout
petit défaut c'est qu'en général on en a
besoin comme un drogué on est en manque
pas le manque de sa dose non le manque
du sentiment vous savez cette fierté
qu'on a quand on a de l'ambition quand
vous réussissez un projet vous dit ouais
il est fait ce sentiment de fierté
ce sentiment de reconnaissance sentiment
de contrôler ce sentiment de puissance
assez bons il y en a dans la salle y
compris oui
et sentiment de puissance le problème
c'est qu'on en veut toujours plus
toujours plus toujours plus alors ça
nous amène à aller plus loin et
malheureusement dans l'ambition il n'y a
pas de fin c'est à dire que c'est un
sentier qui continue qui continue ou en
fait chaque objectif chaque nouvelle
ambition que vous avez c'est pas la fin
c'est juste le début d'une nouvelle et
ça ça vous demande plus d'énergie sur
plusieurs points le temps l'énergie aie
sur soi même le temps je suis persuadé
que dans la salle tout le monde l'a vécu
ben on invente un nouveau créneau
temporel en fait on fait vingt-six
heures sur 24 on travaille toute la
journée on travaille même la nuit on
travaille même quand on dort c'est à
dire qu'on parle à la personne à côté du
coup ouais donc là je vais faire ça
ouais ouais ok superbe
c'est intéressant la deuxième chose
c'est qu'on est au maximum tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps on ne peut pas ne pas être à 110%
et la troisième chose c'est tout simple
c'est con et focus sur ce qu'on fait
juste ça il n'y a que ça qui existent
que ça je ne vois que mon projet
il manque quelque chose je suis en train
de perdre quelque chose en faisant ça je
vois plus mes parents j'appelle puis mon
frère
j'aperçois ma soeur je parle à mes amis
sur facebook
et puis je loupé ça peut-être ma nièce
le plus beau bébé au monde la plus belle
nièce du monde oui je sais vous en avez
aussi mais c'est la mienne la plus belle
je passe à côté de toute sa jeunesse et
ça fait encore plus mal quand vous
l'entendez vous dire tonton ça fait
longtemps je t'ai pas vu tu viens quand
mais c'est pas grave c'est ambitieux ça
passe puis la deuxième chose qui est
intéressant aussi c'est que c'est faux
j'ai pas 110 % d'énergie j'ai plus
d'énergie
j'ai plus d'énergie parce que je le sens
chez moins vif j'ai moins de temps
j'arriverai à me concentrer je deviens
presque énervant irritant je me laisse
les personnes qui sont autour de moi les
personnes que j'aime les personnes qui
travaillent avec moi c'est pas de ma
faute je le contrôle pas et tu la
dernière chose peut-être la pire
j'ai de l'ambition ça me fait grandir ou
je suis grand mais je suis vide
je suis vite j'ai rien à l'intérieur je
en train de faire des projets et en soi
à chaque fois que j'en fais un j'ai un
plaisir éphémère
telle une jouissance au bout et sa part
l'image est forte
c'est violent mais c'est exactement ce
qui se passe et mon but c'est de me dire
comment je vais pouvoir faire pour ré
avoir un plaisir comme celui ci mes amis
me disent manu arrête arrête ton
ambition était en train de devenir
victime d'elle-même motivé non je suis
acteur dont l'ambition je suis capable
de faire ce que je peux je sais ce que
je veux c'est comme ça que je fais là
faire alors j'arrive à un point sur
lequel je suis devant vous aujourd'hui
je me pose la question toute simple si
l'ambition m'a tuer est ce que
concrètement je suis en même temps le
bourreau de mes propres désirs et la
victime de ce que je souhaite faire le
plus au monde
j'ai fait une erreur je fais une erreur
on la fait tous vous avez tous été à
l'école primaire n'est ce pas il ya eu
des doutes je vois qu'à peu de réponses
d'accord on a tous eu un problème et en
général quand on a un problème qu'est ce
qu'on fait on s'acharne sur notre
solution on se dit qu'on va la trouver
d'accord et en s'acharnant dessus on est
sûr de ne pas la trouver
eh bien c'est exactement la même chose
avec l'ambition je me suis trompé je me
suis trompé de questions à me poser la
question était un peu différente
c'est à dire que concrètement ce qui
allait se passer c'était que je devais
me demander une chose simple
est ce que je suis en train de faire et
pour moi où est ce que je fais c'est
pour les autres
bah oui si on y réfléchit bien lorsque
ma prof m'a dit quelque chose
est ce que c'est moi qui ai été touché
ou est-ce que tout simplement j'ai voulu
prouver que j'étais capable de en fait
c'est tout simple est ce que je souhaite
juste être c'est-à-dire apprécier ce que
je fais et mais tous les moments que
j'ai ou paraître
ouah ouah ouah je me suis entraîné pour
se pose là
il ya un homme qui s'appelle gary
chapman un auteur qui a écrit un bouquin
sur l'amour enfin me dire c'est quoi le
rapport
il expliquait que deux dans l'amour que
l'on en a une personne à un principe de
réservoir c'est à dire que si j'aime
quelqu'un mais je lui donne le mauvais
amour il ne se passera rien exemple si
j'ai une petite amie que celle ci a
besoin en fait de moment d'attention et
que je lui donne des cadeaux
j'ai beau lui en donner autant de
cheveux je ne remplirait jamais son
coeur c'est à dire qu'elle se sentirait
en vide et je me sentirai fatigué eh ben
on peut l'appliquer à l'ambition
concrètement ce qui vient de se passer
dans l'ambition c'est la même chose
tout ce que j'ai fait jusqu'à
aujourd'hui je les fais pour les autres
on fait tous pour les autres pourquoi
tout simplement parce que en général
pour les autres à une question d'ego
d'orgueil on a du mal à accepter quand
on fait on veut prouver qu' ici et là je
voudrais que vous leviez la main qui ici
n'a jamais fait quelque chose parce
qu'ils avaient envie de prouver aux
autres allez-y à l'ehec a levé les noms
en général on le fait tous mais on le
fait pour plein de raisons
on va le faire pour sa confiance en soi
pour combattre des croyances pour
essayer de prouver à ses parents pour
montrer qu'on est capables deux pour
aller chercher des croyances limitantes
bref on va le faire pour plein de
raisons qui sont bonnes au départ mais
qui dont le temps ne vont pas tenir
il n'y a qu'une seule et véritable
raison pour laquelle vous devez avoir de
l'ambition
elle tient en quatre lettres s e
nss que je veux dire le sens quand je me
lève le matin et que je suis en accord
avec moi même et que je fais quelque
chose qui a du sens pour moi c'est ce
qui change toute ma vie je peux accepter
de ne pas voir ma nièce je peux accepter
d'être à fond et d'être fatigué à partir
du moment que je suis sûr que ce que je
fais
gelée dans mon coeur pas dans ma tête ou
pas pour montrer aux autres en soi que
ça se voit bien que ça soit pas je m'en
fous je le sais je le sens je le suis
alors j'ai envie de dire que l'ambition
n'a pas tué celle qui m'a tuer c'est
celle qui a été donnée aux autres
concrètement si je dois vous dire
quelque chose il m'a fallu environ 25
ans pour m'en rendre compte
j'ai essayé d'être top model pour une
prof j'ai essayé d'être champion de
france pour montrer à mes parents je
pouvais réussir dans le sport
j'ai même pris mon premier emploi pour
leur dire vous avez vu j'ai bien fait
comme vous avez vous lu j'ai été au
lycée
ensuite j'ai fait un thé ou thé et puis
voilà j'ai pris un emploi tout ça pour
quoi
pour me sentir fidh à partir de ce
moment je me suis dit plus jamais ça ne
m'arrivera ce que je fais doit être une
chose toute simple je dois être aligné
avec moi même que ça plaise ou que ça ne
plaise pas que vous l'entendiez ou que
vous ne l'entendiez pas que ça vous
touche ou que ça ne nous touche pas le
plus important pour moi aujourd'hui
c'est d'être aligné ce qui est drôle
c'est que dans un ted
on doit toujours terminer par quelque
chose et je me suis dit ils pointent en
effet waouh c'est le moment où
normalement les gens se lèvent font une
ola lèvres des pancartes disant manu on
t'aime me jettent des papiers d'avions
mais j'ai pas trouvé
mais quand même j'ai trouvé une petite
phrase qui m'a énormément touché dans un
bouquin celle-ci la conséquence du
conforme il sait qu'on est aimé de tous
sauf de soi même concrètement n'oubliez
pas qu'avant même de parler d'ambitions
le plus important lorsque vous faites
dans votre vie dans chaque fois que vous
avez étant chaque décision que vous
allez prendre c'est d'être d'accord avec
vous même et vous aimez parce qu'on peut
pas aimer les autres si on ne s'aime pas
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]